look at a human being and say you
deserve to be under one roof with the
people that you love but does that give
you a right to break into my house
exactly just break into hello I'm
Ernesto Rocha and I am a proud
undocumented storyteller my name is juan
camilo from Salazar at Rio solare era
for the gringos JC I'm a singer and
actor I'm done gently I'm a spoken word
artist and a paralegal and I was
undocumented for 12 years
Jonathan Miranda and purple hi I'm Julie
I'm a grad student and I'm also
undocumented
Jasmina Saavedra I'm an immigrant I came
to this country through the legal
process
the day after Trump's inauguration I
found my mother at 6 a.m.
trying to find out how much it would
cost to ship our washing machine to the
Dominican Republic she said I just want
you to be ready in case immigration
comes ever since it has felt like my
family and my community have been taking
punches over and over and over again
trying to prove our humanity that we
deserve basic human rights I think it
was never about a very specific country
and a very specific legal status I think
it was a fear of everyone who was
different he put forth the Muslim ban
and through that process a lot of people
lost their green card there's their
permanent resident status - and after
that he came after birthright
citizenship undocumented immigrants and
I think Mexican and document immigrants
in particular were the first to take the
hit
but that category is gonna continue to
grow and it's going to consume a lot of
us well I feel attacked by the other
side Jews because I loved this country
just because I respect the law here I
feel attacked but I cannot feel free to
support my president because they
profile me as a bad person just because
I want the best for the people in this
country right we said the T word there's
a Latino I'm already put in this box but
I'm supposed to think this way
I'm supposed to act this way I'm
supposed to just assumedly go with my
group Trump said very specific things
and they gets twisted around and
presented as like well he thinks all
people all Mexicans are rapists it's
like that's not what he said the Muslim
man it wasn't a Muslim ban they're
banning specific countries that were
already banned under Obama so to call it
a Muslim ban is a very wide umbrella of
Association I lonely I feel threatened
by is by media it is by identity
politics is your JC was saying when
first off I don't have a problem with
the stories you guys have you come
America for betterment but sadly your
minority of another minority of people
that do come across the border for other
not good intent purposes the reason why
I talked mostly about Mexico is because
it's right on our southern border is
right there and our border is totally
wack its weak it's nothing there that's
why I voted for Trump and what a wall is
because even though even come to the
Lehrer process I still want you to be
protected but also you know President
ROM have been saying that you want to
help the good illegal people the people
who really love this country I mean
because you need to a sec no everyone is
good I mean you can be here illegally
and be respectful to this country and
love this country I think there's a
theme here this theme of legality the
way in which Trump supporters have used
this idea of legality has been
completely incorrect and dismissive of
this country's history if you were to
use the same are you man 60 years ago
when segregation with legal you could
have said I don't want black people in
this in this restaurant because the law
says that white people and black people
shouldn't be in the same spot I have the
right to impose that law lost change
laws can be unjust
I believe in America first
I actually believe in America first but
I believe every country should have that
anything how do you want America first
even though these people are not
undocumented the moment I hope that the
Gates initiative which is hopes ASAP
that they come to a country that is
prepared to give them opportunities and
to go for the goals and dreams that they
wish to aspire it's like America first
it's like we start with the individual
so is your life more important than my
life in my world my life is more
important in your life and I do my best
to take care of myself I fill my cup up
so that I can fill up your cup I was
first for me
if community I don't stand behind any
country I can't say that I think
Dominican Republic comes first I don't I
think it's people come first America
first is such a dangerous concept I
don't know if you realize but that's the
reason why we're caught the world is
constantly at war America first is about
white Americans first it's white America
first versus the few people from all
around different countries different
colors who are ok with white America
first because they're gonna get the
second and there's always the temptation
for me to align myself in that place and
say if I just keep my head down a little
bit then I will be next in line too
because guess what I am more privileged
than undocumented immigrants who come
from Latin America who have crossed the
border and that is shameful to me and I
have to every day train myself to put
that thought down because I want to
align myself with people and I know you
said how can I think about another
family when my own family is hurting but
why wasn't America thinking about that
when it came into the Dominican Republic
when it created incredibly uneven
trading deals with Mexico when it bombed
the hell out of my country right wasn't
that for America first isn't that why
I'm here
illegal immigration hurts legal
immigration
it's like you're waiting in line to get
into this this place and for you to you
know go to the back of the line stand in
line and wait and to watch people cut in
line in front of you it's a big [ __ ] you
to my family it's a big [ __ ] you to the
whole system it's a whole it's it's not
about a wall [ __ ] the wall it's about
principles like you said it's based on
principles I've even waited there would
be no need for a wall in general when
you come here illegally and you got cut
off now you're in a position of being
like in the middle class or anything the
worth class were now you're paying more
taxes for someone to not pay taxes and
now you're paying for their education
there was good that could gun for your
children that could have gone for
American citizens and now we're giving
it to them we had a process for a green
card in place and guess what
we waited those two years and what
happened was we were denied because they
said your parents aren't making enough
money that happened two more times every
time we were denied my parents decided
to stay because our entire lives were
here our entire community our church
community our friends when you say there
is a right way to immigrate here and
there is an illegal way and you use a
big fat label on all of that you're
really obscuring all these diverse
details about people's lives it's it's a
really dangerous rhetoric when you begin
to put good versus bad legal versus
illegal listen I crossed into this
country I migrated I walked with my
brothers and my mother I was a poor kid
who had no shoes how could I know that
there was a legal process and when I
came into this country I absolutely
found out what it was to be entering
into that legal process I'm in that
process now 11 years and Counting
so what you're doing is instead of
looking up to the systems that are
putting all of these situations into
place you are looking down to the people
most downtrodden we did nothing to
deserve this it is actually the systems
that are play that you have to look and
reflect and say why is this happening to
your family why is it that your people
about why
Oh simplify to their own government why
the one a fire and demand America and
that is insulting why why you drive
victimize yourself there is no
victimization my how are you sir how
dare you say that there is a
victimization between my mother making a
very real strategic decision and logical
to say I am going to reunite my kids
together to live under one roof
everyone have their own story and I'm
fine with this but now we're talking
about the thousands of people trying to
jump our territory language is important
language is important how you discuss
the people who I mean I'm just tired to
feel like oh I cannot say this because
they're gonna get offended I mean I'm
offended because I'm an American because
I'm followed in love
I'm offended because I'm a Christian
woman because I'm a woman with principle
with model with fate something that's
very interesting to me is when religion
comes into place right and we say I am
an American I am a Christian yet you are
unable to put aside the political and
look at a human being and say you
deserve to be under one roof with the
people that you love regardless of what
the government decides to call you but
does that give you a right to break into
my house to break into his house the
next statement is becoming a legal
citizen should be easier
if you look at the way that the
government issues visas it's in a
completely political system who gets it
what time how many years and so when you
think about citizenship it absolutely
should be easier in the legal process
but let's not lose sight the citizenship
also means the way that you move about
in your values and say I can be a
citizen of this country because I am a
human being and I think we have to
recognize that undocumented immigrant
don't want to be undocumented if we were
up to a documented immigrant they will
go show up apply for a green card and
then apply for citizenship and that's it
the system is currently failing because
we are not appointing people who are
able to understand why people are coming
people who are able to connect with the
different stories that people are
bringing for us but the problem is we
need all to agree but even legal or
illegal immigration need to be control
because you can see what is happening
here in California we see our street
looking like a third-world I would
respect that I would respect that
opinion if I didn't know that more
people were leaving the u.s. than coming
in that undocumented immigrants are not
the one
predominantly committing crimes in this
country you see that people are more
likely to leave now than some let me
tell you this I'm sorry to disagree when
people are complaining about gun they
say oh we need gun control because even
one life matter well the same thing even
if they are document people having
committed a crime even one life matter
let me tell you this I have a sister who
become a widow
at the age of 34 with two little boy
because her husband got killed for an
illegal alien
my brother-in-law life matter the wall
for me is a message of love from our
president to his people because he want
to protect the people from this side of
the wall
even you guys you want to protect
everyone from these days of the wall but
we need to understand hummus first how
can I help someone far away if I not
able to help the people who is close to
me the reason why I am so against the
wall number one economically very
infeasible and number two I don't see
the wall as being a physical barrier
between two countries I see it as a very
symbolic barrier between people people
who are running for their lives are
still going to come because trust me
your desire to live is going to help you
find a way to get over some wall you
know that's that's not the problem
walls barricades barriers are not the
economic moral answer everyone in this
room can make America great by finding
solutions rather than finding problems
that's what a lot of people like to do
we like to point out what's wrong and
not try to figure out what we can do to
make it better we all agree that the
immigration system sucks like you do
what again like you're into the field of
I'm a paralegal but I've been a me
trooper senator okay and so you know
more about it than I do I don't know
[ __ ] compared to you so I want to hear
your more unit perspective and I'm open
to that that's what American needs more
of you have something I don't you're
superior in that field and if we look at
ant elect before skin tone or before
politics that would open up more doors
to make America great we're making
America even better it's people who are
in this country who want to fight for
the betterment of it as was making this
country great but I really appreciate it
[Music]